foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday October 21st I'm Julie Chang for
the Wall Street Journal filling in for
Zoe Thomas
chill intelligence has made it
incredibly easy to create original works
of digital art programs like open ai's
Dolly 2 and stability ai's dream Studio
let you type in almost any phrase to get
a computer generated image and while
this can be a useful and even fun tool
some worry about the potential drawbacks
or even dangers our senior personal Tech
columnist Joanna Stern has tried out
both programs and she's been looking
into what they could mean for artists
and anyone coming across those images
online and she joins me now hi Joanna
thank you so much for being here anytime
Joanna you tried out two of these AI art
generators how did those images turn out
it really depends I will tell you that
you will always get something back
that's a little bit entertaining and
probably humorous and sometimes you'll
get back stuff that you just can't
believe was made by artificial
intelligence and not a human I'll talk
about a couple examples that I used in
the column one was a technology
columnist who was trying to write a
column those were the words I put into
Dolly and what I got back was a picture
of a man his face was a little bit
deformed and he's writing with a pen on
a keyboard he's also wearing a very ugly
purple tie
another one I tried was a female
technology columnist in a spacesuit
typing on a laptop in outer space
and when I got back was a very cool
image of outer space sort of glowing
stars blue background behind this person
and then the person in an astronaut suit
typing on a laptop and that image is
very cool I would probably make it my
phone background yeah that image does
sound really neat but how exactly does
this technology work and where do they
get the images so it's very complicated
technology and I spoke to many experts
to just try to make this as simple as
possible for myself and for my readers
and my viewers and what I was really
taught and what I think is the best
comparison is that the artificial
intelligence which is living on the
servers of these companies
is being shown flash cards
the artificial intelligence is learning
by looking at millions and millions of
flash cards and what's on those
flashcards well it's images and then
it's labels so it's a picture of
something in let's say a monkey and it
looks at thousands of pictures of
monkeys that are labeled monkey and so
the AI starts to learn that is what a
monkey is and then it looks at some
pictures of podcasting right maybe
that's a microphone or people talking
into microphones and then through all of
this deep learning and all of this
technology when you put in the phrase a
monkey recording a podcast the
artificial intelligence starts to build
that image pixel by pixel and it's not
putting together images it's already
looked at it's building that image from
scratch are there any limitations to it
though for instance is there anything
that they wouldn't let you create so yes
one of the images that I love that I've
made is of Elon Musk holding a Twitter
bird as you would expect you Elon Musk
would now have as a pet but I wasn't
able to make that image through Dolly
because Dolly restricts making images
with people who are public figures they
have some other restrictions too which
we can talk about I was able to make
that image though using stability ai's
dream Studio that image generator
doesn't have restrictions on using
public figures and so when I put that
prompt in I got back quite a realistic
looking version of Elon Musk it doesn't
look like a photo of him it's very clear
it's not really him but there is enough
similarity there that when I'd tweet
that photo I don't need to say who that
is people would know that's an Elon Musk
look alike and what are some of the
other restrictions with Dolly yeah so
both Dolly and dream Studio do have
restrictions on making explicit content
right you can't really make porn with
these they also have restrictions around
showing really offensive or quite vile
lint content Dali specifically limits
the ability to generate violent hateful
or adult images I did try on both of
these systems The Prompt a photograph of
a terrorist attack and both of them did
produce images though the dolly one was
definitely less offensive or less in
your face on some of the imagery it was
of a police car it was a little bit
stylized there was some sort of fire in
one of the backgrounds but on dream
Studio it definitely went a step further
and it showed deformed bodies on the
ground with guns and fire so there's a
difference between the two systems but
there's also this bigger question about
which of these companies will come along
and not put these types of restrictions
in place
were there any signs that maybe these
images were AI generated yeah the
biggest indicator that something is
generated by AI right now is the quality
if you look closely at pretty much
anything you can see that there are some
issues some warping of the image
especially if it's trying to mimic a
photograph or it's trying to look more
lifelike and so with those terrorist
images the heads weren't really quite on
the bodies correctly there were
definitely guns but it didn't look like
they were being held in the hands so
there were a lot of signs in that image
that this wasn't real but everyone I
spoke to for the story said this is
going to get so much better so fast and
so that's the big question going ahead
as we start to get images that look like
they might have been taken by a
photographer how do we know the
difference openai is really encouraging
people to say and credit when they share
their images that it was made by Dolly
they also put this watermark in the
bottom right of the image so you can
more easily know that this was made by
Dolly but of course you can crop that
out stability AI does not add a
watermark
I want to talk about some of the other
potential downsides to this technology
specifically about how this may impact
artists how have they responded to AI
art taking off
so I've heard mixed reactions from
actual creators obviously this Tech is
good right now but it's going to get
great and so I think the bigger
questions about the future and how
people use this but right now some
professional illustrators and animators
I've spoken to are actually using these
tools right they like the idea that they
can make certain things by typing in
prompts and then integrate it into their
works if you're an artist and it's
ripping off your style well then you're
not going to be happy you know another
potential issue is bias Tech has been
criticized for having bias in it did
that show up at all while you were
testing out the program yeah it
definitely did and I'll come back to one
of the prompts that I put in in the
column which was a technology columnist
writing a column and all the images
returned in that prompt were of white
men sitting at computers or writing on
notebooks and as a technology columnist
that is not a white man I felt like hmm
well I guess I'm not really represented
here so the companies told me that this
is something they're working on
specifically open AI which owns Dolly
said that they continue to invest into
research on mitigating bias and improve
results all right Joanna we're gonna
have to leave it there our senior
personal Tech columnist Joanna Stern
thank you so much for breaking this down
for us thank you and that's it for Tech
news briefing this week our supervising
producer is Chris sinsley and I'm Julie
Chang filling in for our host Zoe Thomas
thanks for listening and have a great
weekend
[Music]
foreign